SéSébastien.
F Fabien Paquette, directeur
gégénéral et responsable des
vavaccins chez Pfizer Canada.
BoBonsoir.
- - Bonsoir Monsieur Roy.
- - La dernière fois qu'on s'est
paparlé, ça paraît il y a Milan.
OnOn était dans un petit creux e
vavague. Il y avait des
didifficultés avec les doses. L,
elelles arrivent en nombre
imimpressionnant. On a préparé n
tatableau. Moi de mai : 2 millis
dede doses Canada et 457 000 au
QuQuébec. En juin, on monte à 24
mimillions de doses par semaine.
OnOn a l'impression que ce n'est
plplus une préoccupation pour vs
quque d'acheminer un nombre de s
imimportants.
- - Effectivement, Monsieur Roy.
MaMaintenant, on a mis en place
totoutes les informations et les
prprocédures nécessaires pour
popouvoir non seulement avoir ue
lilivraison qui est faite de fan
cocontinue et récurrente, mais
auaussi de s'assurer que si on t
dadans une position de pouvoir
auaugmenter le volume comme on a
fafait au mois de juin avec au-
dedelà de 2 400 000 doses prévus
popour chaque semaine. On contie
dede mettre de l'avant ce genree
plplan. Notre objectif, c'est
d'd'accélérer la cadence le plus
popossible éliminé et les plus
prpressés des Canadiens dans les
plplus brefs délais.
- - Votre grand patron de chez
PfPfalzer a dit il y a quelques
sesemaines : ça va prendre une
trtroisième dose sûrement et pe-
êêtre un quatrième. Où vous en
êêtes dans cette analyse? Est-ce
quque ce une logique commerciale
ouou de santé?
- - C'est certain que ce sera ue
lologique de santé, parce que la
dédécision d'avoir besoin d'une
dodose de rappel pourra être bae
susur des résultats scientifiqu,
dedes analyses cliniquement
dédémontrées le besoin ou non
d'd'avoir sa dose de rappel.
AcActuellement, les équipes étus
sosont mises en place pour évalr
lele contexte et voir est si ily
a a une dose de rappel, quel sea
l'l'intervalle. On va attendre s
rérésultats des analyses et des
seses études pour le confirmer.
DaDans les prochains mois, on
dedevrait avoir une réponse à ç.
- - Pour les jeunes de 12 à 15 s
dadans votre cas, mes 17 ans por
leles écoles, qu'est-ce que vote
vavaccin, c'est exactement la me
ququ'on va donner aux jeunes?
C'C'est juste que les études ont
momontré qu'il était efficace,
auautant efficace chez les jeun?
- - Effectivement, il y a une
ététude qui a été complétée aux
EÉtats-Unis pour le groupe des
adadolescents de 12 à 15 ans, qi
a a démontré un excellent profil
dede sécurité est également une
efefficacité remarquable pour
nonotre vaccin. Ce qui permet dc
mamaintenant de pouvoir avoir
l'l'homologation de notre vaccin
PfPfizer/BioNTech et pour ce
grgroupe d'âges qui a été octros
hihier par Santé Canada. Donc ue
exexcellente nouvelle qui permet
dede pouvoir accélérer le rythme
auauprès d'une population qui dt
êêtre vaccinée compte tenu de
leleur risque, pas tant pour les
coconséquences pour eux-mêmes,
mamais particulièrement parce
ququ'ils sont des vecteurs
popotentiels de transmission du
vivirus. Souhaite effectivement,
avavant la fin des classes, ça a
plplus vite que l'on croyait. Vs
l'l'avez dit, c'est une bonne
nonouvelle. Par ailleurs, vous
vovoyez comment la pression
ininternationale qui monte pour
quque vous et les autres
phpharmaceutiques suspendit
tetemporairement vos brevets de
sosorte qu'on pourrait produire
susur la planète, l'Afrique du d
esest ailleurs, beaucoup plus de
ququantité de vaccin pour
dedesservir les pays qui en ont
momoins. Est-ce que Pfalzer est
prprêt à écouter ses demandes?
- - On comprend que c'est un enu
ququi est extrêmement importantl
fafaut réaliser que Pfizer comme
l'l'ensemble des compagnies
ththérapeutiques veut favoriser
l'l'envoi des vaccins partout sr
lala planète. On a augmenté nos
cacapacités de production à 2,5
mimilliards de dos cette année t
onon parle de plus de 3 milliars
dede dents année prochaines. Ça
dédémontre cette volonté de
popouvoir offrir le maximum de
vavaccin à l'ensemble...
onon ne croit pas que la levée s
brbrevet est le meilleur moyen.n
pepense que la meilleure façon e
popouvoir offrir davantage de
vavaccin à l'ensemble de la
plplanète, c'est de pouvoir
fafaciliter davantage la
prproduction où ça fonctionne
bien, donc par exemple dans le
cacas de nos usines et de
s's'assurer que l'expertise quia
étété mise en place continue de
popouvoir favoriser une
acaccélération de la productiont
dede déploiement des vaccins.
- - Je lisais quel argumentairee
PfPfizer, c'est-à-dire que la
rerecette est tellement
cocompliquée, que même si on
enenlève les brevets, il ne sert
papas capable de le faire
aiailleurs. Est-ce que c'est un
pepeu ça que vous dîtes?
- - C'est une chose d'avoir la
rerecette, mais c'est un autre
avavoir le connaissance,
l'l'expertise et les capacités e
prproduction, d'avoir le matéri,
d'd'avoir tout ce qui s'appelle
leles produits nécessaires à la
fafabrication du produit. Tous s
éléléments font en sorte que ça
auaugmente le niveau de complexé
etet on n'est pas certain que ça
dedevrait accélérer la cadence.e
nene pense pas que ça va accélér
lele rythme de faire ça de cette
fafaçon-là. On est plus dans un
cocontexte où avec leurs
pepersistants et les matières
prpremières qu'on a et de la
fafacilité de pouvoir produire
dadavantage de doses, c'est
prprobablement la meilleure façn
esest la plus rapide de pouvoir
ofoffrir davantage de vaccin à
trtravers le monde.
- - Offrir davantage de vaccin n
teterminant, est-ce que ça veut
didire et on la fait pour le VIà
l'l'époque, est-ce que ça veut
didire couper les prix beaucoup
popour certains marchés? Est-ce
quque vous êtes prêt à négocier?
QuQuand je disais que la pressin
momonte, l'organisation mondiale
dudu commerce, M. Biden, au
CaCanada, on déconstruitit ça, .
MaMacron qui est d'accord avec .
VoVous sentez la pression
ininternationale. Pfizer et les
auautres, vous faites beaucoup
d'd'argent en ce moment. C'est
ququoi votre réponse? En avez-vs
unune autre carte à jouer?
SoSouhaite absolument Monsieur
RoRoy. Je pense que ce qu'on a
dédémontré avec notre partenarit
avavec l'organisation... c'est e
popouvoir fournir des vaccins ds
seses pays en voie de
dédéveloppement à un prix tout à
fafait raisonnable qui correspod
àà leur capacité de pouvoir est
seseul offrir et je vous dirais
ququ'on à différentes échelles e
prprix à travers le monde pour
jujustement répondre à cette
sisituation. Je peux vous garanr
quque pour ce pays en voie de
dédéveloppement, les prix sont
apappropriés pour les conditions
etet leur capacité d'après paye.
OnOn veut continuer d'offrir ces
papartenariats et faire en sorte
ququ'on puisse davantage mettreà
didisposition des doses.
- - Mais la levée temporaire des
brbrevets, c'est une fausse bone
ididée de vous.
- - C'est pas la meilleure façon
dede procéder. On pense qu'il ya
d'd'autres façons de faire pour
ararriver au même objectif que
d'd'offrir davantage de vaccin x
gegens qui en ont besoin